Hawaii birthplace of the Kenyan usurper
is the first state to challenge the
new-and-improved Trump travel ban my
signet look right here this is Trump's
signature my signature looks like a
fence
no one's getting through that signature
lawyers for the state of Hawaii took a
break from drinking pink drinks through
long straws on a perfect Beach to ask a
federal judge for a temporary block on
the travel ban claiming it would result
in the quote establishment of religion
in the state of Hawaii contrary to its
state constitution and would quote
inflict immediate damage to Hawaii's
economy educational institutions and
tourism industry then they climbed into
their Ferraris and fish tails back to
meet Higgins Burpo and Robin Masters of
State
all right all right I'll turn it up
these one you'll can't handle Magnum to
my forum I can play it again come on
shut up
I'm a white guy that's the only time I
get near the word Magnum it's kind of
nice to be near it three on it you can
tie off the end but but it doesn't
really comedians this is of course the
Trump administration second to travel
ban the first one got struck down by
those pesky judges and their stupid
separation of powers and goddamn
intimate understanding of a legal system
and whatnot so how do you think this one
will shake out how do you think this
little shake out anyone can buzz when
part of the first travel ban affected
seven Muslim countries people protested
government heard those protests and now
the band only affects six countries so I
think it's gonna go pretty well whoa
okay so Iraqis off the list but now
Hawaii is considered an enemy combatant
yeah yeah but we're going to attack them
any day now I really yeah babe I think
it's great what Hawaii's trying to do
but I don't think they're getting a lot
of Muslim visitors to Hawaii like spam
is their number one food
[Laughter]